quick question is there gonna be a  tenacious d rock opera that's one of the  rumors it's out there l to the yeah hail  to the we're working on a rock opera  it's a post-apocalyptic musical comedy  and the idea is that you know you've got  like Pink Floyd the wall mm-hm and  you've got Tommy the who and those are  the only true rock operas in existence  you hear the word rock opera all the  time there's only two rock operas ours  is gonna go right in there somewhere in  there in that area and all the rest of  the supposed to drop operas can suck it  because they saw that's a pretty harsh  thing why do I get so mean I don't know  trumpian yeah I mean it you're you're  not who you used to be men can't you  change your minds a change do you man  yeah Eve Oh  you